Matt Ryan back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Matt I'm doing great
risk thanks for having me on of course
love having you on nine years Matt
that's a long time you're almost pushing
double-digit years in the NFL that's
incredible I know it goes by in a blink
man it really does i can't believe it's
your nine already what do you think of
when you see somebody like Carson Wentz
coming off the campus at North Dakota
State going to a no and dak Prescott
performing like this about remembering
when you first started in the league oh
yeah that's impressive you know I know
how how hard that transition is how
difficult it can be think both those
guys have done a great job I haven't
really seen that play all that much but
got a chance to watch a little bit of
the monday night game for for Carson
Wentz and he looked good man he really
did he played well and compete it and
threw the ball well so I really good
start for those two guys so do you
remember your first touchdown do you
remember that I I do i do is actually my
first pass first off in the NFL it's
correct you uh see ya Mike Jenkins on a
skinny post from the back side I
remember it do you remember how many
yards it was really yards I dunno if I
think it's 62 63 yards you met ryan look
at so far the only one i remember the
actual distance why I remember my first
broadcast in Redding California the day
I lost the keys to the news car when I
was shooting the video of the high
school game so I guess you should
remember the 62-yard touchdown pass to
michael chugg right that's exactly right
I know and now you're here in your ninth
year after a very nice win on the road
in Oakland what what what kinks I guess
are you working out with this offense in
the first month of the season what are
you working on as you get in to New
Orleans for this big game on Monday
night Matt but you know I think the
thing for us you guys still get a little
bit better in the red column I thought
we did a nice job in Oakland made some
plays we're able to punch the ball in in
the red zone but it's something that we
haven't been at our sharpest in that
area so we got to continue to try and
get better down there and come away with
more touchdowns I guess you need to have
more ricochet passes off the hands of
Tevin Coleman then I right yeah I think
we just need to start designing all of
our places like that it's no you drew it
out that's the way you drew it up that's
definitely so who is
would you say the starting running back
of the Atlanta Falcons Matt jeez I mean
both our guys are so good i mean it's
it's to me it's a 1a 1b I mean these
guys are both talented you know devonte
had a monster year last year total was
nicked up at certain times but you know
we've got both of those guys going and
healthy and they're fresh for the entire
game I think that makes it extremely
difficult on the defense to defend us
all right I'll cop to having Tevin
Coleman on both of my fantasy teams Matt
help me out here how many carats is
gonna get come on now let's get out to
it what do you go fake anything I think
he's gonna have a few man here great
ghrelin okay this past week to get in
the end zone I think both those guys are
just go a lot of special help so mm-hmm
and now what is it like to prepare for a
game in the Superdome cloud you know
that's that's probably the biggest thing
I've learned throughout my career is
that communication is difficult down
there particularly in night games and so
it's going to be important for us I
think last week was a good tune up for
us playing in Oakland that's a loud
place tough place to play they can they
can get rally so the communication you
know needs to be on point and I think
we'll be better served ahead in New
Orleans because of our experience out in
Oakland last week Matt Ryan joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show no I don't
talk politics with with people but would
you are you gonna DVR the debate you
know the debates going on while you're
playing on Monday night Matt I just
found that out today oh you know so I
just just do a quick Twitter search or
something like that the next day I see
the highlights of it okay no do you dr.
me no DVR if you're focused on what's
going on on that field first yeah that's
it that's it for week 3 of Monday Night
Football against the saints so what
goals do you talk about in your nine I
mean what do you how are you focused on
being the goal oriented person that you
are a near nine of being in Atlanta well
I think the biggest thing for us is it's
about you know consistent improvement
I've been on teams where we played
really well at the beginning of the year
and not as well at the NFL teams that
you know have been up and down and
inconsistent for the best teams I've
been on you know are the ones that have
continued to get better weekend and week
out throughout the year and that's
that's a goal for me
and the goal for our off then to to just
get a little bit better every week and
trying to prove that we move throughout
the season and in terms of being a team
leader so much has been discussed about
Jay Cutler after Monday Night Football
and we always talk about body language
with him and whether that's something
that the team picks up on or it grates
on the team what is your philosophy on
that well you know I think it's an epic
body language is important and you're
not something that at the quarterback
position I've always tried to focus on I
think no matter you know who you are
when you get into total guys are looking
at you and so for me that's something
that that you know I work hard on to try
and have the demeanor that the guys can
look to and understand that we're going
to have solutions or favorite thing wall
and you know I think that starts with
the way you prepare and how you handle
things during the week and it carries
over the in game situations but that's a
huge point of emphasis for me what about
in the postgame podium too man well i
think that's that's one thing
everybody's personality is a little bit
different and you know i think you need
to be yourself whatever that is and i
think guys pick up on that pretty
quickly if you're if you're fake are you
not being yourself to me you know
teammates etc they filter through that
pretty quickly so I just try and be
myself up there and and the guys know
who I am well spoken like a true natural
right there that's right we need that
and nickname to take off well you know
what what I i I'm you know how much I
like you Matt but I'm gonna have to
point the finger in the direction of
number two here okay I need a little
help I've tried all I can you know I
think it's all I falls on the antenna
getting that job promoting it well I
mean you've talked about it when we're
on here but I don't believe you fully
embraced that over Matty ice mad I don't
I think it's the Ferryman's me it's
there are some passionate fans about the
demoniac nickname so but I'm with it I'm
with it whatever it works okay well help
me help you to use the old phrase you
know help me help you it's all I'm
trying to say man unless you don't look
it's I'm fine i'll give you just like
one last
chance to say you don't like it and I
won't take it personally just go ahead I
I don't mind it I think it's a good
nickname okay fantastic well you're
you're out here you're out here on
December 11th week 14 against the rams
and your coach Dan Quinn has I think
offered for me to be an honorary coach
to address the team I mean I can do that
for you to Matt we can address this then
at that point in time would you be up
for that I mean yeah you talk to the
guys about I will see what their
reaction will be to that I'm looking
forward to hearing this roar aah okay
aah pep talk that you're going to
deliver well I did it for Michigan and
they put it on Central Florida a couple
weeks ago that's all I'm saying that's
all I'm saying sometimes there's a
little bit different level of
competition in college than there is a
little bit tighter in the area taking me
to be stronger with that okay the
corners can close quicker right
basically what you said that's exactly
right okay the speed of the game is
different Matt thanks for calling in
have a good game on Monday night I
appreciate it Rick thank you you got us
Matt Ryan of the Atlanta Falcons here on
the rich on stir the rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience